what was the guardians galaxy 2 james
castro and guardians galaxy 2. so you
were we did we did i was in that too
yeah we were we were in that together we
were also in the movie hit and run
together yeah
no scenes together though those scenes
together
puts me in like everything and it's but
it's always like the mechanic you're the
idiot who comes in and says one dumb
thing and as he drives away and it's hot
rod
right right
but you know there you go yeah uh i
appreciate it so what was that like did
you have to audition for guardians or
james just say hey you want to play this
character no he's just like
it's a small part it's you're a ravager
james likes to work with his friends as
you know you know he's
you know he may not always cast his
friends as like big huge parts but like
he he'll fill a movie with like
his friends in smaller parts here and
there and it's i just remember being on
set
of guardians 2 and you were doing some
scene and he was like ag
do it like this say it like this and
you're screaming and you're yelling he's
just adding he's trying to find funny
stuff that you can do extra things that
you can do
to just i think when we were doing
guardians to
when dailies would go out to like kevin
feige and them i don't even know if
that's how that would work but they
would see footage and
they liked you they were like these guys
were really funny so
i was supposed to die in that movie you
know the scene at the end where
where michael rooker kills everybody
with zero yeah
and so we did that much later like i
shot most of my stuff when we did the
stuff with you
and then i came back like three months
later to shoot just my death scene
and we shot it and then james was like
i would shoot something else
just to make
just have footage so in case we want to
you're still alive
and so we just shoot a really quick
scene of me on the ground crying
that i've been stabbed and my beer has
exploded and that was it just to have
you know in case he wanted to use me
again doesn't that feel good though
you